vierter tag der belastungs übung das
ziel endpunkt näher doch die härteste
prüfung steht den soldatinnen und
soldaten noch bevor ein mindestens 65
kilometer lange orientierungsmarsch mit
zusätzlichen aufgaben bringt alle an die
körperlichen und psychischen grenzen
nach einer kurzen regnerischen nacht
bereiten sich die teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer auf den anstrengenden
orientierungsmarsch vor
das war doch wenigsten geschlossen und
kreativ senders war
man zählt das relativ unwichtig aber ich
glaube das ist ja jeden zugegangen
das schlafsack war ungefähr fünf kilo
schwerer mann hat in der früh kontakt
haben das war alles komplett maß von
viel schlafen dann immer die rede
aber man hatte ja gezwungen das nur die
augen sagt zu halten die stimmung in der
gruppe ist trotz schlafentzug
überraschend gut
gut so denn mitleid gibt es vom
übungsleiter ohnehin kleines natürlich
versetzt man sich immer wieder hinein
nachdem auch selbst auf die eine oder
andere art in der ausbildung diese
solche belastung übungen und belastungen
gespürt wird
man muss aber immer versuchen das dann
etwas auf die seite zu schieben und
objektiv zu beurteilen weil auch das
kommission nach wie vor an dass die
eingeteilten kommandanten und die
gesamte der gesamte lehrgang beurteilt
wird und trotzdem versucht man dann zu
unterstützen aber wie gesagt wichtig ist
dass man objektiv bleibt und nicht
jemanden besucher benachteiligt heute am
vierten tag geht es praktisch ins finale
der belastungs übung die männer und
damen marschieren donnerstagmorgen von
hier weg werden eine maß leistung von
ungefähr 50 bis je nachdem wie weit
brauchen bis 80 90 km/h gehabt
absolvieren mit stationen
es geht jetzt wirklich darum dass sie
erstens die letzten tage verkraften den
schlafentzug die belastungen physisch
sowie psychisch sich selbst noch einmal
zusammenraufen
die stationen miteinander bewältigen und
dann gemeinsam morgen um die mittagszeit
herum in 1 ankommen wie wir alle teile
dieser weg marschieren
winter werde in den schnee ok ja noch 30
startschuss für den orientierungsmarsch
die erste hürde ist ein 35 meter hoher
steinbrocken das ab sein gilt als
mutprobe für die meisten jedoch nichts
neues schlimmer ist das schlechte wetter
und unerwartete stehzeiten in der kälte
also körperliche sache für heuer wegen
der kälte lassen und weniger wegen der
körperlichen anstrengungen ewig warten
müssen wir ab zu station macht in
deutschland fertig waren wir nicht so
massig oder einzeln oder nicht heute
dann nachher wieder vollgas weiter geht
hier kann das trockene kleidung
es ist äußerst klein um ausrüstung so
kommen alle josef jacobi treten ich bin
jetzt schon zwei stunden über zwei
stunden in der zeit hat man natürlich am
hof meter machen kenne da war es ist
wird sogar comics morgen am fuß
endlich für gruppe 2 12 hat das warten
ein ende
auf geht's ans abseits
also ist das buch das sonst wird es
keine kopf die stimmung um wahrheit
seien neue mini zurück weil sie sind
kult und worden
wenn jetzt alle unten seine hand
gemeindlichen anpassen
ich freue mich jetzt die schüler aus
marschieren kaltwasser zogen erst einmal
zeit dass wir daran wird auch die andere
gruppe hat mit der wartezeit im regen
schwer zu kämpfen
es geht bei dieser übung darum dass wir
die leute ja mal psychisch physisch
bisschen an die grenze heran führen dass
sie dann in dieser phase auch noch
natürlich die gruppe führen müssen dass
sie auch die dienstaufsicht wahrnehmen
dass sie spüren dass es ihm mit der
gruppe also gemeinsam besser geht ja es
ist nicht die absicht die leute zu
quälen wir bereiten sie natürlich vor
es gibt gewöhnung special und es ist
diese ganze übung nicht nur einmal
sondern sie lernen ja auch im rahmen
dieser übung es gibt diese gesinnung
stationen was sie dazu weiter lernen
also wir bereiten sie selbstverständlich
vor
und dann ist doch das bestehen dieser
übung dann eine hürde auf dem weg zum
unteroffizier ähnlich wie es beim
offizier ist da war es heißt problem
auswachsen dass man fast wieder so sich
da wirklich scheitern lernen muss also
schon immer war körperlich anstrengend
wie soll das weitergehen könne weil
natürlich lang angeordnet um und
ziemlich viel zeit drauf gegangen ist
das nennt sich zwar für den nächsten
stunden wie möglich zur nächsten station
kommen dass man auch hell weil aufmacht
seine stationen glaube nicht so lustig
spätestens jetzt beklagt sich niemand
mehr über die kälte einen verwunderten
transport auf zeit fordert den
soldatinnen und soldaten alles ab 30
kilogramm marschgepäck zusätzliche
munition und ausrüstung ein verwundeter
soldat auf der trage und das alles im
laufschritt deswegen meister und nachdem
wir viele trage befreite haben
anscheinend müssen wir halt noch mehr
gas getragen sei dass mein tag der
körper kann noch schnell energie tanken
denn die zeit drängt
die gruppe will so weit wie möglich bei
tageslicht marschieren
denn das orientieren bei nacht ist um
einiges schwieriger mit dichten nebel
hat allerdings niemand gerechnet
das risiko sich bei schlechter sicht zu
verlaufen ist um einiges höher
und nun wird es auch schon dunkel
die gruppe 2 12 hat sich trotz
abenddämmerung und dichten nebel nicht
verliert und erreicht die nächste
station abc schutzmaßnahmen sollen dort
geübt werden
abc steht übrigens für atomare
biologische und chemische kampfstoffe
der leichte schutzanzug gehört zur
grundausrüstung der soldaten und
soldatinnen und ist immer dabei mit
voller montur maschinen die gruppen dem
nächsten zwischenstopp entgegen
das atmen mit maske ist anstrengend und
der luftdichte anzug bringt die
teilnehmer ins schwitzen
doch in erd- leighton erwartet sie
zumindest die erste warme dusche seit
vier tagen und ein warmes abendessen
schlaf gibt es heute keine die gruppen
marschieren weiter und haben auf dem weg
zum ziel noch einige hürden vor sich in
der nächsten und letzten folge wird sich
zeigen wer das ziel in enns erreicht